porque el ser humano siempre hecho arte
cuál es el sentido del arte esto no es
una pregunta que durante cientos de años
se han hecho teóricos filósofos artistas
entre otros y asimismo han habido muchas
respuestas todo indica que su uso
depende de tres factores primordiales
época lugar geográfico y función está
función puede ser estética religiosa
terapéutica educativa política social y
un largo etcétera y todas las mezclas y
combinaciones imaginables entre ellas
pero eso no es lo mismo que sentido cuál
es el sentido detrás de estos usos
la respuesta es que no existe una verdad
absoluta al respecto en qué sentido no
es algo que podamos estandarizar sentido
viene de sentir y cada cual siente de
manera única el arte vendría a ser el
medio a través del cual exploramos y que
analizamos de manera profunda y
sustancial aquello que se ve limitado su
descripción por la razón entonces
recurrimos al arte como medio para
explorarla canalizarla y reinterpretar
la
el proceso artístico comienza con un
estado previo para lograr un sentir
pleno
debemos silenciar la mente despojarnos
de ideas soluciones y juicios previos
para entrar en un estado sensible ver a
través del sentir ver a los demás a uno
mismo y al entorno a este estado lo
llamamos contemplación esta atención
sensorial será el motor del proceso
artístico el brote creativo la
inspiración que su significado viene de
recibir el aliento
de esta manera el artista podría
inspirarse de sí mismo y de lo que lo
rodea sea por ejemplo la grandeza del
volcán recién negado la ternura de tu
hija que te abraza un sentir propio como
el dolor frente a la muerte de un ser
querido o la obra o la obra de otro
artista que nos como ve este sentir
inspirado es el motor que nos lleva a la
necesidad del arte es que el arte es una
actividad tremendamente esclarecedora y
sanadora a sí misma ya que nos lleva a
ampliar nuestra capacidad de ver
reconocer y reconocernos en otros puntos
de vista nos ayuda a desarrollarnos a
ser más conscientes que es aceptar más
posibilidades y nutrirnos de ellas
es una actividad que nos ayuda en esto
que llamamos la expansión de la
conciencia
yo no nací en una familia de artistas
sino más bien de buenos espectadores fui
testigo como mis padres gozaban viendo
películas escuchando música leyendo
viendo libros de arte y arquitectura aún
puedo ver a mi padre con los ojos
llorosos recitando los los versos del
poeta de esta región jorge tellier bajo
el cielo nacido tras la lluvia escucho
un leve deslizarse de remos bajo el agua
mientras pienso que la felicidad no es
sino un leve deslizarse de remos bajo el
agua
a los 5 años comenzó mi formación
musical a mí ya mis hermanos nos tomaron
clases de piano con una profesora de
formación clásica ella con mucha
paciencia y buena voluntad nos enseñaba
la forma correcta de tocar este
instrumento posición de las manos
lectura musical ejercicios de digitación
escalas etcétera una actividad no muy
amable para un niño de sólo cinco años
que se escondía debajo de la cama cuando
le tocaba su turno de tomar la clase
en el colegio nunca fui muy bueno para
artes plásticas y manualidades me
gustaba pero como no era bueno sumado a
esto en cierto punto nos obligaban a
elegir entre artes plásticas y música
situación completamente inentendible e
injusta para mí y muchos otros niños que
nos gustaba realizar ambas actividades
entré a estudiar flauta traversa en el
conservatorio en donde me llevé la
ingrata sorpresa de ver mi insecto en un
medio tremendamente pauteado con
exigentes cánones y criterios técnicos
por donde yo no veía posible cómo
desarrollar mi creatividad mi visión
sensible
dejé la carrera y me surge una pregunta
entonces cómo se debe enseñar música
entré a estudiar pedagogía música en
donde me encontré con un escenario menos
violento pero bajo el mismo paradigma
educar no era sacar extraer lo que se
tiene como se refiere su etimología sino
más bien nos enseñaban cómo hacer para
que los niños y niñas canten y toquen
correctamente sus instrumentos para
lograr el orgullo de sus padres y
maestros en los actos escolares y de fin
de años educar no era más bien entrenar
es que hemos terminado educando un arte
sin sentido obsesionados con los
aspectos técnicos en la forma más que de
fondo enfocados en los resultados y
descuidando los procedimientos hasta
olvidar su primordial sentido
al educar algo sin sentido corremos un
enorme riesgo provocar la
automarginación quizás de por vida de
una de las actividades constitutivas del
ser humano la educación artística debe
brindar los espacios para que niños
niñas y adultos lograr un vínculo
significativo con el medio
abriendo el camino a través del sentir
ofreciendo experiencias vivenciales
amables acorde a sus capacidades físicas
procesos internos como dijo picasso
todos los niños nacen artistas el
problema a seguir siendo artistas cuando
crecemos
veo la educación artística como si fuese
una gran y generosa casa con muchas
puertas y ventanas cómo y por dónde
entrar no es lo más importante lo
importante es entrar y maravillarnos con
lo que podamos descubrir dentro querer
esa casa sentir la propia para recurrir
a ella cuando necesitemos explorar nos
observarnos reconocernos y disfrutarlos
cuando llegué a vivir a villarrica está
en esta región tan particular de nuestro
país deje maravillar por su energía y
kit es un lugar tan potente tan lleno de
una naturaleza desbordante que no fue
difícil verme ensimismado en este
momento de contemplación en momentos tan
cotidianos como encender el fuego en la
mañana o escuchar el sonido del ayer de
la lluvia cayendo sobre el techo de la
casa o también momentos más
espectaculares como cuando se asoma la
lava incandescente por el prater del
volcán
aquí también conocí más de cerca la
cultura mapuche a su gente como visión
en una ocasión tuve el honor de ser
invitado por una comunidad aún
wetripantu el año nuevo mapuche
esta ceremonia tiene que ver con la
renovación de la vida cuando el sol y el
calor empiezan a acercarse y se prepara
la tierra que ha descansado para una
nueva siembra y augurar una buena
cosecha y se celebra justamente el día
más corto del año solsticio de invierno
la ceremonia está llena de ritos están
los puros son las danzas nos encantan
los cantos y los cantos los juegos y
toda la comunidad participa en este
lugar y sin muchos antecedentes me dejé
llevar me entregaron una física que es
un instrumento de viento que produce una
sola nota y sin ningún tipo de
instrucción previa todos los presentes
nos sumamos a una experiencia sonora
maravillosa en donde girando y bailando
alrededor del rewe durante que excepto
de lo sagrado durante unos minutos
fuimos todos un solo sonidos marcados
por el constante latir del control
comprendí rápidamente que la función de
las físicas era responder se unas a
otras
[Música]
a su vez sonaba el rebotar magnético del
trompo las cascabeles y el tronar
poderoso de las turcas el conjunto de
todos estos sonidos formamos paisaje
sonoro similar a estar inmerso en la
mitad del bosque durante una fuerte
tormenta en donde todo suena diferente y
a la vez uno
la potencia y simbolismo de esta
experiencia tuvo un profundo impacto en
mí
creo que este es un ejemplo muy
esclarecedor de que se puede vivir una
experiencia artística inclusiva profunda
y significativa sin la necesidad
exclusiva de mis habilidades
psicomotoras o la formación previa que
yo puedo haber tenido al respecto
es que creo que debemos reenfocar la
manera de ver el arte y su práctica de
vincular esta idea de la experiencia
exitosa de los resultados o los
reconocimientos que yo pueda recibir al
respecto sean estos sociales económicos
o de mis pares y entenderlo como un fin
en sí mismo
stalin a cesc y el famoso actor y
pedagogo teatral dijo amal arte en ti
mismo que a ti en el arte es que creo
que es un poco como en el deporte yo no
salgo a trotar ni hago deporte para
convertirme en un maratonista ni que me
reconozcan necesariamente por ello lo
hago porque me gusta porque me hace bien
porque me conecta con algo constitutivo
de mi ser que mi cuerpo físico el arte
vendría a ser el instrumento para
conectarnos con el cuerpo emocional que
todos tenemos que la igual que el físico
debemos cuidar y desarrollar
si mi obra logra la contemplación y
aprecio de los demás es un regalo
maravilloso y un gran abono para
continuar haciéndolo y desarrollando me
siempre cuidando en no condicionar mi
libertad creativa en función de este
reconocimiento ya que puedo condicionar
también mi libertad de exploración la
sorpresa que pueda encontrar y mi
potencial expansión de conciencia
sus enzimas profesora de ecología
forestal de la universidad de columbia
nos compartió en su charla ted que
recientes estudios han descubierto que
los bosques se comunican a través del
subsuelo a través de sus raíces existe
todo un submundo interconectado como una
gran red de informática por donde los
árboles comparten información y
nutrientes hasta medicina creciendo ante
todos como un gran ser
creo que estos organismos no son tan
diferentes a nosotros todos somos
diferentes individuos diferentes árboles
crecemos en lugares diferentes y de
maneras particulares con nuestros nudos
y ramas nuestros bosques de personas
podríamos llamarlos culturas ya que por
abajo o por arriba en un plano
misterioso estamos conectados entre
todos nos nutrimos y sostenemos así los
árboles más grandes y viejos nos
inspiran con su experiencia los más
osados conquistarán nuevos lugares
otros fertilizar a la tierra al morir
todos estos puntos de vista toda esta
experiencia toda esta información nos
ayuda a crecer interna y exteriormente
impulsándolos hacia la luz de manera
singular lenta constante y virtuosa
el arte su práctica de contemplación es
la puerta de entrada para conectarnos a
esta gran red para que enriquecido de
esta sinergia podamos también aportar
nuestro punto de vista sensible
colaborando a este gran organismo hace
su expansión y evolución muchas gracias
[Aplausos]